So I want you to fill out this report card, which says, how well is
AFS doing as a secure system. And I want you to think about
some of the challenges that a secure system
has to face. The first one is mutual suspicion.
Meaning can I trust the server. Can the server trust the client? Can I trust my
fellow users in the community? Is that challenge
addressed by AFS? I want you to give a
binary answer, yes or no. The second attribute I
want you to evaluate the Andrew file system on
is whether the users are protected from the system,
or in other words, can the system do something
bad to the users? So that's the second attribute
I want you to evaluate. Once again, a binary
answer, yes or no. And the third attribute is confinement of resource
usage. In other words, does the system ensure that no
particular user can overuse resources available
in the system. The resources could be network bandwidth and so on. Again, binary
answer. The fourth thing that I want you to evaluate the AFS system is
on authentication. Whether it provides authentication in
both ways. Both authenticating the server to
the client and the client to the server. The last attribute is the integrity of
the server itself, meaning can the server be compromised in any fashion. That is
the last attribute I want you to evaluate. Once again binary answer, yes or no.